nous accueillons aujourd'hui benjamin
mee les types pour parler de la
situation au tchad ce pays d'afrique
centrale le simili ti et le représentant
au canada du parti des transformateurs
un parti d'opposition bonjour le semi
liquide bonjour monsieur samir je suis
dit je vais revenir un peu sur la
situation au tchad les derniers
développements donc le 20 avril dernier
il y a moins de deux semaines dans comme
le président tchadien idriss deby qui
venait de remporter la sphère l'élection
présidentielle pour un 6ème en bas et
tué lors de combats avec des rebelles
juste après un conseil militaire de
transition présidé par son fils mahamat
idriss deby qui errent âgé de 37 ans ce
cancer a dissous le gouvernement et
l'assemblée nationale
on a ce conseil est appelé le cm et le
cnt a promis des élections dont dix-huit
mois d'instaurer un couvre feu il ya eu
des manifestations il ya eu aussi des
morts en djamena récemment il ya eu six
morts en 2001 et dans une autre ville
alors pouvez vous nous parler un peu des
derniers développements des
développements des dernières heures où
on est la situation elle ne développe
pas des animaux mais hier on a procédé à
l'enterrement de presque une dizaine blé
des gardiens qui était combien cette
édition d'ailleurs il manifesté l'aimé
vie mais le conseil militaire de
transition a envoyé de l'arbre et
l'armée dans l'autre sens ce jeu donc il
y encore les stigmates aujourd'hui et le
pays et la souffrance et ceux qui sont
blessés on doit les soins et sera donc
dans l'ensemble et c'est cela le double
port ethernet
néanmoins il faut se dire que les cadets
sont debout et plus de questions d'eric
thulliez par ce régime vous épinglez
elle a chanté si ça passe il opère et
rien n'a changé alors quelle est la
position de votre parti le parti des
transformateurs on est dans la course
et dès le début nous arnaque
ces régions vous voyez le père d'abord
et plus de huit semaines et kazim à
chaque semaine on sortait pour
manifester dans la rue
et on s'inscrit également dans la même
logique n'est pas constructif parce que
nous on a fait des propositions pour que
le message qu'on n'accepte pas et une
succession monarchique
et rien n'indique un autre ex à la
constitution fut-elle manipuler mais
cette constitution en vigueur
nani dit nulle part qu'il faudrait voir
ce que le chef paraît son fils les
remplace donc nous on a proposé comme
tout le monde comme tout l'état tient il
faut un régime civil
un gouvernement de transition civile qui
tirait sa légitimité de la constitution
aussi simple que ça et militaires ou en
euros à la branche de la sécu de la
sécurité walla est donc un vice
président qui sera nommé et de la page
de sécurité et là dessus mais c'est ça
la proposition que nous avons faite et
je vous dis pas mais là là là
dire que nous portons quand même le plus
grand poids et nous avons trimé cd puis
épuise hier dites moi vous n'êtes pas le
seul parti d'opposition il y a les
autres ce qu'on peut prévoir une
alliance entre des partis d'opposition
la veille des élections
vous étiez il ya une d'héroïne coalition
mais les pâquis transformateurs
n'étaient pas dedans
est ce qu'avec ce changement de donner
ce qu'ils sont pas imaginer une alliance
des oppositions et une avenue que nous
avons toujours de les chercher ce qui me
concerne
et oui en ce moment la plupart partis
politiques d'opposition
mais à part l'ancienne majorité b tous
ces partis sont d'accord pour qu'il y
ait un régime civil
ça c'est le dénominateur commun vis dans
ma chaque partie peut avoir ses
stratégies mais dans l'ensemble tout le
monde d'ici débreake il y ait un
gouvernement de transition civile qui va
convoquer par la suite une sorte de
conférence nationale ou un des bras
inclus il faut rappeler locaux monde où
peut mener ensemble sur place de
nouvelles règles pour les élections
voyez vous ça c'est ce que vous demandez
mais lors des funérailles d'idriss déby
le président français emmanuel macron a
apporté son soutien à la junte militaire
de même que quatre autres pays du g5
sahel la mauritanie le mali le burkina
faso et niger
quel est votre commentaire à cette
situation parce que vous avez l'appui de
la france et de ses quatre pays et vous
de notre côté
oui et à titre personnel je vous me
demandez est ce que la france fait là
dedans le tchad est un pays souverain ce
que je sache et que nous avons des
textes et exception la même portée que
celle de la france
bénédicte et le suisse doit remplacer le
le père parce que c'est une des
considérations sécuritaires
je ne souviens qu'il est ce que pour
cette raison on a demandé à ce que les
militants gay cette incohérence
mais le français dans son rôle actuel de
ternat lister ces jours ci voulait
garder les images ça fait la
démonstration que le pays est devenu le
protectorat de la france le tag est
devenu séjour à la démonstration a été
faite mais je livre le drian est dirigée
complètement le chef de protocole vous
le voyez se déplacer par les gens il est
vraiment dans son rôle ni les coûts
représentent le chat pour la france la
france évidemment le tchad ce n'est
qu'un territoire et les humains grand
terrain d'entraînement pour ses armées
et s'il ya une certaine utilité baisse
et que nous sommes pour aller combattre
les quêtes la région du sahel pour être
un avant garde et mourir pour ça ça
l'intérêt premier qui guide la france
évite aussi les intérêts jean dans les
ressources naturelles et ce sera on ne
peut plus rien d'autre que cela
pour lui le taxer sans vie variable dans
sa stratégie régionale
je vous comprends les rebelles du front
de la pour l'alternance et la concorde
au tchad
c'est qu'ils seront définies oui ben
cccd tanière il faut le dire et c'est
m'a dit qu'il a et qui dirige ce parti
laïque et un gang aux politiques comme
il est
et donc il était très longtemps à
l'extérieur une table et le moment venu
lorsque ils ont observé que des bingos
qu'une discussion et que nous sommes un
riz a aucune porte qui s'ouvre et qu'un
débit à organiser des élections qui sont
recrutés pour le voit les résultats
cet orage ok il n'y avait plus et ils
ont fait le choix des armes
nous ne respectons c'est parce que nous
partageons mais nous comprenons
ils ont agi et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'ils ont réussi à arriver à la
situation du décès du chef d le
changement actuel il est venu après
débile et il est monsieur miletti la
dispora tchadienne va organiser le
samedi 1er mai une manifestation à
montréal devant le consulat de france
pourquoi alors pour dénoncer clairement
le rôle trouble que la france joue aux
tables et surtout la table bénédicte
lagonaire aux pensées de l'état de
transition
c'est contre nos textes et c'est
inacceptable pour la plupart gagner et
puisque ces régimes militaires locaux
uniquement par la protection le
parapluie de la france
il faudrait qu'on s'adresse directement
à la commune et s'adressait à dieu qu'à
ses engins et une expression qui le dit
donc pour nous on doit dire clairement
et ça s'inscrit dans une stratégie ombre
couvrir le front des stations de
l'ayguade a dans tous les pays où la
diaspora tchad ainsi pour votre
information
aujourd'hui la france a dû reculer et il
a reçu la diaspora tchadienne de la
france à l'elysée c'est pour vous dire
que nos actions portent et les plus
question de s'arrêter en si bon chemin
ce pourquoi le sam edi nous allons
continuer à marcher
la question sur la france on que nous
revenions à un régime civil tire sa
légitimité dans la constitution
les deux parties puissent faire la
compétition et le peuple décidera en ce
contexte là quel rôle pourrait jouer le
canada est ce que et est ce que vous
espérez vous avez des leviers qui
peuvent vous aider à faire entendre
votre auto il ya quelques il ya un mois
on était à nous nous avons écrit hier
nous avons des lettres à la maison les
ministres
nous avons également écuyer aux
conservateurs et même au bloc et mp duty
ont pour leur expliquer clairement la
situation qui se passe portable et il
faut qu'ils protègent sonel moi j'avais
au parti libéral de libéral que un pays
comme le canada pays qui se dit libre de
droit des libertés et chaque fois que il
y à un régime tyrannique quelque part
maltraite son peuple
le canada est toujours debout pour
rester la compagnie compte la russie est
encore dans bien des pays
mais lorsqu'il s'agit de l'afrique il
s'agit du tchad
le canada est resté silencieux et nous
n'avons pas compris alors pour mons et
s'impliquer parce qu'ils sont dans la
même institution que le tad il faut des
affaires ils ont des donations d'un père
abbé je me réjouis pour dire que les
etats unis se sont prononcées clairement
mais la cour pourrait régime civil la
france aux tirs et aux pédales et
l'union européenne également a dit que
bon effectivement il prévient cependant
que le nom issu du canada est resté
silencieux
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs dans
l'est de nos slogans on a dit au canada
les tchadiens ont besoin d'hommes ils
soient de café rase et du canada mais
ils sont restés jusqu'à là silencieux et
je me désole pour mon pays d'adoption
un pays qui est toujours à la vente et à
la liberté
merci beaucoup monsieur benjamin me
l'étais je rappelle que vous êtes le
représentant au canada du parti de
transformateurs un parti d'opposition de
droite merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci